hey hulu fans it's kris jenner i'm so
excited that we're back with our new
reality show we have a lot in store for
you all and i can't wait for you to see
it in the meantime check out the rest of
what's coming to hulu this month
[Music]
i'm excited for this new chapter and
i've been in this game long enough to
know that you just have to be yourself
who you texting ken does his name rhyme
with feet
what do you think dying is like just
like floating on water they've opened an
investigation into your connection with
the death of conrad roy but i didn't do
anything wrong there are text messages
thousands of them the whole thing is
alive
share your thoughts on hunger daylight
savings time save the tree frogs brother
look who's cracking under pressure look
i just got to figure out how to bring
people together
who wants croissants
that's the white i've heard all day you
think that your crush on gabriella
campos is cal artworthy this semester
i'm gonna make my move oh yeah name one
time they've made a move
is she in slow motion again yeah music
playing in the background
you were a lost cause
[Music]
why is mom so different around other
people
hey you want to tell me why you didn't
come home last night not really
this isn't a game mod
it's always been a game
the crime is murder
the murderer is one of you
used to be a nut man
yeah i was
i've always wanted to meet him i bet you
got all kinds of stuff just stirring up
inside
holy mary [ __ ]
we are competing for the same job it's
impossible to trust each other i'm in
this you can trust that
the one the only
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
why don't you guys go ahead i'll park
the car
it's been very special that makes you
look like you ate eddie murphy it feels
great to have 13 episodes to wrap up our
eighth and final season
is your state the best it's time to
prove it this is american song contest
we've got music we've got money we've
got celebrities this is going to be a
hot show tonight
my dad was always a hero to me nice cake
dad and my grandmother first slap pick
your poison leave me alone you can't be
here you're under house arrest in an
extortion case this is a house it has to
be your house
city hall is back in business today i'm
getting more done than beyonce you can't
take it back the hive is always
listening
hey easy easy oh you took that like a
champ sir
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you